Hey. Really extravagant. The queen is with her puppy
Live in a castle outside the government. How much does it cost?
The answer is 40 million pounds.
This is equivalent to 65 pence per person per year for the royal family.
Of course, it's still 23 pence to get a shield, but you don't have to pay so much.
After all, those are your money.
Why can the Queen take the money? Well, this is a bit complicated.
The story begins with this man, George III.
He is known for losing the United States. But little known - and more interesting - is
He seems to have a mental illness called porphyria (porphyria).
This problem has an unusual side effect: it turns your stool from a normal, uninteresting brown into a pleasant purple.
Going over the problem - returning to the royal family to collect taxes.
George was unable to pay his bills and his debts piled up.
Although he has a large piece of land,
But the rent of the land is not enough to support his expenses.
He proposed to Parliament: for the rest of his life, he will give up the rental income from the land.
In exchange for a fixed annual salary and pay off debts.
The parliament accepted his proposal,
Because it is profitable in the long run.
Is the parliament doing the right thing? Back to the present, let's calculate the gains and losses.
The following ten pounds of paper money will represent 10 million pounds.
The cost of the royal family today is £40 million a year.
The UK's income from royal land is £200 million.
200 million income minus 40 million wages is equal to 160 million pounds of profits.
That's right: Britain earns £160 million a year from the royal family.
So stop your complaints about the royal family and the royal family's expenses and uselessness.
The royal family contributed greatly to Great Britain. Make another arithmetic per capita:
The £160 million divided by the population of 62 million is about 2 pounds and 60 pence.
Because of the royal family, you actually pay less than 2 pounds and 60 pence a year.
But maybe that’s not enough.
Because you are an extremely greedy old thing. Why not kick the royal family and earn 100% of the income?
Because the land still belongs to the royal family. Crazy George is not crazy enough to hand over everything.
It’s just profit. But not only him:
Since George III, every monarch has voluntarily handed over the proceeds of the land to the United Kingdom.
Note: Voluntary. If the government stops paying royal life and public expenses,
Then the royal family will have to return their land income.
And the tax, dear monarchy, will only rise and fall.
Plus 160 million is just the easiest money to calculate from the royal family.
Don't forget their huge and invisible gold swan:
Tourists. Although a bit annoying to the locals,
They blocked the subway and refused to stand on the right.
They put money in the UK: sightseeing, public transportation for absurd short trips,
The hometown is thousands of miles away. Of course, they don’t just come for the royal family.
But the most expensive is the royal family. Who spends the most? The United States.
After buying enough maple syrup and cheap illegal tobacco,
What is their next stop?
United Kingdom. Americans fly over the ocean
Look at the castle on this land that is not made of plastic. Why do Americans think French castles are boring and annoying,
And the castle in Britain is awesome? Because the real monarchs are still using the castle.
The Tower of London is amazing.
Just because the guard uniform is true,
Rather than a lame historical reappearance or modern real-life role playing. This is the embodiment of a vibrant queen.
Everywhere you see, she is scattered with her.
The rot is magical and makes visitors stunned.
12 million visitors spend £7 billion a year.
Suddenly, direct income is insignificant.
But maybe you don't have a cold on the monarch's eternal gold mine.
You admire the republic and do not like the political power of the royal family.
After all, the government’s rights come from the king, not the people.
Yes, I admit that in the old days of the broken, this is indeed a reasonable concern.
But the modern queen is not a dangerous political beast, but a cat that goes to the claws.
Her powers are limited to the resolutions of the parliament that are generally agreed to by the Kabuki Theatre.
Nothing will change unless the royal family is expelled from the government, except that you will no longer live in the magical United Kingdom.
It is boring in England, Scotland, Wales and the United Republic of Northern Ireland.
English abbreviation URESWNI. It doesn't sound like it sounds like it.
But maybe I am wrong - maybe the queen is a political time bomb,
Just waiting for the opportunity to launch a war and dissolve the parliament.
But before that day, God bless the Queen.